familiar but horrific scenes school
children run to safety in yuvalde texas
as a gunman murdered 19 of their
classmates and two of their teachers
inside
after this gun control advocates said
this time it would be different actor
matthew mcconaughey came to washington
to meet with lawmakers the president and
then the press to try and make sure that
is true
they wore
green high top converse
with a heart she had hand drawn on the
right toe because they represented her
love
of nature camilla's got these shoes can
you show these shoes please
wear these every day
green converse with a heart on the right
toe
is the same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
how about that
he was born in uvalde and he has spent
the last week there talking to families
of the victims bringing their stories to
washington and pleading for change
mcconaughey is calling for raising the
legal age when you can buy an assault
weapon from 18 to 21. he wants to see
increased background checks new laws
that make it easier to take guns away
from people considered unstable there is
a bipartisan group of senators working
on proposed legislation but it is not
expected to go anywhere close to as far
as that
the house is taking up legislation to do
those things but first they will hear on
wednesday from a little girl who was
here in the classroom she took blood
from her murdered friend and spread it
all over herself in order to play dead
it will likely be shocking hard to
listen to testimony from a traumatized
child
another attempt to make sure this time
it actually is different
patty culhane al jazeera washington